- La Grande-Bretagne, durement
touchée par la quatrième vague,
devient le premier pays
à approuver un nouveau type
de médicament anti-COVID,
offert sous forme de pilule :
le Molnupiravir.
Mais d'autres pays pourraient
bientôt suivre si l'on se fie
aux autorités réglementaires
européennes.
Le Molnupiravir, fabriqué
par la multinationale Merck,
est un antiviral développé
à l'origine pour soigner
la grippe puis testé avec
succès contre la COVID.
Ici, pas de traitement en
intraveineuse, sous supervision
médicale, comme c'est le cas
pour les autres médicaments
disponibles.
FRANÇOIS-XAVIER LACASSE, prof.,.
- Ce qui est intéressant, c'est
que c'est... bon, c'est un autre
arsenal, c'est une autre arme
qui entre dans l'arsenal pour
la défense contre la COVID-19.
Le premier avantage,
je pense, c'est que c'est
un traitement par voie orale.
Puis, on sait que la voie orale,
c'est la voie ro
- Le mode d'emploi est simple.
Il doit être pris à la maison,
en début d'infection,
à raison de deux comprimés
par jour pendant cinq jours.
Il est offert uniquement
aux patients à risque
d'hospitalisation élevé en
raison de problèmes de coeur,
d'obésité ou de ,
par exemple. Même si les données
concernant l'efficacité de cet
antiviral n'ont pas encore été
publiéperts anglais
qui les ont consultées ont été
convaincus. De 14 %, en moyenne,
le risque d'hospitalisation des
groupes de patients étudiés
aurait diminué de moitié, à 7 %,
avec ce traitement, selon Merck.
- En clinique, ils ont démontré,
exemple, qu'il y a des gens qui
étaient atteints de la COVID,
en prenant le Monulpiravir,
s une certaine période
de temps, relativement courte,
je dirais peut-être
de 24 à 72 heures, voir
une baisse de la charge virale.
- Au Canada, ce médicament
est toujours en attente d'une
approbation par les autorités
réglementaires. S'il reçoit
le feu administrations
publiques devront également
se prononcer sur son prix,
estimé pour l'instant
à 800 $ par traitement.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M